well getting groceries is one of those
necessities in our lives we simply can't
avoid but unfortunately a hike in prices
is really just putting the squeeze on a
lot of families eight news now reporter
victoria saha joining us now live from
the studio with a look at what you can
do to kind of stretch your dollar when
you head to the grocery store a number
of factors are impacting your grocery
bill starting with a labor shortage
weather related issues and pandemic
shutdowns but there are ways to work
around this to put food on your table
and staying in your budget
monet brooks is a single mom doing what
she can to feed her family very
frustration i have four boys so i'm
feeding the army every day you see my
basket last year her weekly grocery
bills were around 150 dollars when we
spoke with her today as she finished her
grocery shopping her bill was
402 dollars
from 150 last year she isn't alone other
shoppers are also walking out with fewer
items in their hand this is like 30
dollars and i have two two bags you know
i have like cooking oil and something
for dinner
and a cake in order to find out what is
causing the price hike we reached out to
the nevada retailers association they
say accessibility to some items and the
pandemic slowdowns seem to be the cause
free pandemic it used to cost about four
thousand dollars to get a container a
cargo container of products from an east
asia port into los angeles and it used
to take about 40 days
now that price is 24 000
and it takes anywhere from four to five
months according to the u.s bureau of
labor statistics the price for beef
chicken or eggs increased 10.5 percent
in the last 12 months particularly beef
which rose
17.6 percent
he also says when buying certain items
think about the processing behind it and
the labor it would take we also reached
out to a fitness expert he suggested
during these times trying to buy canned
vegetables they can be healthy if
they're sodium free and always a lot
cheaper this is also a time to try to
not overindulge and portion control
denis um sorry dense foods such as
potatoes and yams can help you feel full
so you don't go through your groceries
quicker
good tips thanks victoria so it's not
just groceries a gas price is driving
north again according to aaa las vegas
drivers are paying an average of 3.86
per gallon that is down just a little
bit from last month but it has been
rising the past couple of days if you've
tried to fill up and we're paying a
dollar 23 more than the same time last
year so we wanted to hear from you on
twitter have you noticed your grocery
bill going up take a look at this nearly
90 percent said yep they've noticed an
increase when they shop at the grocery
store